Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
thor love and thunder galactus and x-men deleted
scene video we just learned about a whole bunch of
easter eggs and deleted scenes we'll break it all
down because they're metaphorically and literally
a huge deal if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll
be doing she-hulk episode videos starting next
week after episode 1 drops we're doing a disney
plus giveaway for memberships for that too all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your theories about galactus
and x-men in the mcu i'll name a new giveaway
winner in one of my marvel videos next week but
the big news you probably spotted in your feeds
is marvel just released a new deleted scene from
the portion of the movie at omnipotent city where
thor jane foster korg valkyrie go to get zeus and
the other god's help in fighting gore the god
butcher there were actually many deleted scenes
from this portion of the movie i'll talk about
the other ones later in the video like the big one
metaphorically and literally is obviously galactus
and some of these other x-men characters the whole
idea with omnipotent city is it was meant to
include so many different gods and other powerful
cosmic characters from across the mcu that there's
just no way that they had enough time in the movie
to feature all them like there are thousands of
them in the background of the scene of the godhead
but to explain why a character like galactus could
show up at omnipotent city because galactus isn't
a god in the mcu the way that thor is the way they
were using omnipotent city in the movie they were
just including a lot of other powerful cosmic
characters like the celestials there too like
there were a couple of new celestials that we
hadn't seen before so it makes sense if you're
including like really really powerful cosmic
characters like that you'd also include a version
of galactus but if you look at this scene here
zoom and enhance it depicts one of the sections of
the godhead you know around this big chamber here
that they featured in the background of all these
scenes like i said there are countless sections
each of them having this many gods in each section
so there are probably way way more deleted scenes
and easter eggs of gods like this zoom in enhance
we'll start with the biggest ones here like there
are obviously many many gods here this is their
version of galactus who looks very much like old
school galactus very purple from the comics and
look right next to him this isn't the juggernaut
himself this is meant to be cyttorak the god who
juggernaut gets his powers from and the god who
dr strange's crimson bands of cyttorak spell came
from when he was using it in avengers infinity
war against thanos they also call this item during
the first doctor strange movie that they used to
trap kaiselius in the crimson bands of cyttorak
the reason why they call both of them the
crimson bands of cyttorak is because one of
them is a spell based on Cyttorak's power and one
of them is a relic imbued with cyttorak's power
kind of like the crimson gem of cyttorak where
juggernaut gets his powers from the sacred gem
shall prepare himself to receive the power of the
crimson fans of cytorak there are ton of other
gods here too like over to the right you see a
version of hercules just sitting right next to
them this actually looks kind of like a version
of aries over here too there were a bunch of
other greek gods like we saw a version of athena
actually in the movie we saw a version of dionysus
but there were many other greek gods they didn't
include i'll talk about those other deleted scenes
at the end of the video though but like we did
see a version of hercules show up at the end of
the movie in the post-credits scene where zeus
declared war on thor and the asgardians and sent
him to kill him that wasn't meant to be another
avengers 5 kang dynasty incursions or secret wars
teaser that was a teaser for something more like
a war of the realms type of event that they might
do is like another mini avengers crossover movie
like captain america 4 new world order is like a
mini avengers crossover movie civil war is another
good example of that like a thor based movie where
he's like the main character where you have a
ton of other crossover characters and it winds
up being more of a war of the gods war of the
realms literally situation but talking more about
galactus early on i'd actually wondered if they
teased characters like silver surfer or galactus
through thor love and thunder somehow because old
school thor encountered galactus a bunch of times
encountered silver surfer a bunch of times it
looks like they had a plan to do that initially
i think because galactus is a big part of the end
of the gore of the god butcher storyline in the
comics so the comic book version of gore the god
butcher very different in the way that thor fought
him and defeated him later in that timeline after
they've defeated gore the necrosword continues to
exist in this sort of void but at the end of this
timeline you have a much older version of thor and
it's basically earth slowly dying its last breath
like it's one of the last remaining living planets
there are no other planets for galactus to feed
on so he comes for earth and it becomes basically
thor versus galactus thor using the necrosore to
try and defeat galactus but it's happening in the
future of that timeline so i think it's pretty
easy to assume why they didn't want to actually
include galactus in the movie like we'll just
get rid of this and include him in some later
storyline slightly different version of the
character because one you also have to kind
of explain why he's there like there's this
whole explainer that you have to add on top
of all the crazy stuff that's going on during the
movie also showing off his physical appearance
looking like this kind of blocks them into this
version of galactus ii and i think the version
that we'll wind up seeing in the mcu eventually
will look a little bit different what they might
wind up doing long term though is just because
galactus is such a big concept they might leave
him for marvel phase seven like he could be part
of the next saga after the multiverse saga we're
also not gonna get the fantastic four movie to the
beginning of marvel phase six and it makes sense
that they would want to wait to include them first
in the mcu like the new versions whichever those
are going to be and then bring in silver surfer
in galactus and because they did that in the fox
marvel movies kevin feige said their big thing is
doing a version that we haven't seen before like
doing something with the characters we haven't
seen before and that means not just going straight
back to silver surfer and galactus so it sounds
like when they do introduce those characters in
the mcu like it'll be a slightly different version
of galactus with a slightly different backstory
bringing the cyttorak character in the mcu would
also brought its own challenges with it like
canonizing more x-men mutants related stuff which
they're doing right now like it makes sense that
they want to introduce more x-men characters when
people think of the juggernaut though they mostly
think of that funny x-men the last stand scene
introducing the character don't you know who i am
i'm the juvenile i still laugh every time
i see that vinny jones clip juggernaut was
also a big character during deadpool 2 we
know that deadpool is coming into the mcu
so technically that would canonize that version
of juggernaut to the mcu when they cross over
the funny thing about this version of juggernaut
2 is that even though he does look way more comic
book accurate like he's huge like comic book
juggernaut he's actually voiced by ryan reynolds
himself like they just changed his voice a little
bit if you listen really carefully you can kind
of pick out ryan reynolds in there somewhere
i'm going to rip you in half now juggernaut is
professor x's stepbrother they did a version of
his origin story during x-men the animated series
and we just saw a version of patrick stewart live
action professor x inspired by x-men the animated
series like they literally played the x-men the
animated series theme song when he wheeled in in
the same looking chair in the same looking outfit
so i think the idea is that there is a version of
juggernaut that exists on this planet like on this
planet the 838 universe all the x-men characters
are wearing much more comic book accurate versions
of their costumes juggernaut became professor x's
stepbrother because their fathers worked together
so his abusive father remarried to professor x's
mother to get her money as a child professor x's
power started to manifest he would accidentally
invade kane marco's mind who detected it and
thought that he was doing it on purpose also
he felt like his father loved professor x more
than he loved him so he kind of grew to hate
him over time eventually he became a mercenary
then they reunited during the korean war and
both found the cave with the temple of cyttorak
where he found the crimson gem of cyttorak and
read from an inscription that gave him the power
of juggernaut they did the version of this during
x-men the animated series the inscription that
he reads sounds very much like the inscription
on thor's hammer the spell that odin put on it
whosoever touches this gem shall possess the
power of the crimson bands of Cytorak henceforth
you who read these words shall become forevermore
a human juggernaut the gem imbued him with the
powers of cytorrak. Cyttorak is also known as the
destroyer the lord of oblivion the master of the
raging storm he's an immensely powerful god from
another dimension way back in earth's history
about a thousand years ago he had a contest of
champions with a bunch of other gods and they each
imbued an item with their power allowing the first
mortal that touched the item to gain a fraction
of their power and they would battle it out to see
who the strongest was that's where the gem came
from that gave him all the powers of juggernaut
the whole idea with juggernaut's powers is they
effectively make him invulnerable like one of
the only earth-based characters who isn't like the
phoenix force for instance like jean grey with the
phoenix force that could fight him is a version
of the world breaker hulk like regular hulk isn't
quite as strong he had to become world breaker
hulk to beat him his only real weakness is mental
attacks and that's only when he's not wearing his
special mystical helmet which is why when they're
taking them down usually their go-to move is to
take his helmet off some of the other gods here
in this deleted scene look like they're the aztec
gods i think they're going to reference some of
those during black panther wakanda forever because
it sounds like neymar's people in atlantis descend
from ancient aztecs and they worship some of
the aztec gods in the mcu the same way that
the black panther wakanda characters worshiped
the panther goddess boss who was also featured
during thor love and thunder they didn't really do
that much with her so you could also consider her
a bit of a deleted scene this is her in her human
form normally when she appears to black panther
she appears in her panther form one of the other
major deleted scenes from this big god head scene
at omnipotent city was lena heady as a version
of hera you may have heard about this because
we found out that she was in the movie because of
some weird lawsuit with her agency suing her for
not paying commissions on being in thor 11 thunder
like wait a minute lena heady was in thor love and
thunder what was she doing the whole idea is that
they were just trying to set up more of zeus's
backstory in his family so to speak his god family
in the mcu it sounds like she was also meant to be
in the background of one of these scenes with
the other greek gods just going on about zeus
being ridiculous but part of the idea is they
wanted zeus to seem like a dirtbag so that's why
you see him with all these other women who are
not hera during the movie especially during the
post-credits scene when all the women are nursing
his wounds there were a lot of other deleted
scenes too especially with the special effects
in the way they made things look like this is a
much more comic book accurate version of gore the
god picture that they had planned on including in
the film the big reason why they didn't include
the tails and why they didn't make his face look
the way it does in the comics is because taika
watiti said that he wanted to avoid comparisons
one to voldemort because even though marvel
fans will understand is a completely different
character a lot of casual fans who don't read
marvel comics or don't know anything about gore
would just immediately think of voldemort the
minute they see this face and apparently the
other reason is that christian bale didn't want to
do a lot of motion capture like completely replace
his face so that's why they didn't do the tails
either as far as i know they don't have plans to
release a lot of these deleted scenes on the dvd
they might include a couple deleted scenes but not
everything and there was a lot of stuff they got
rid of like the movie is close to two hours long
they shot enough scenes to do like a four hour
movie but it's usually like that for all marvel
movies but the thing is is a lot of marvel
movies are closer to like two and a half hours
so if we get into more cool easter eggs for
characters like galactus juggernaut even
silver surfer in the future the mcu movies
or series of course i'll do videos for it
because she-hulk episodes are starting next
week there'll be a lot of like hulk related
easter eggs world war hulk planet hulk a lot of
that stuff going on in the mcu so all my she-hulk
episode videos will start posting next week after
they start releasing the episodes make sure you
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that we'll also get more black panther wakanda
forever trailer video soon too while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new she-hulk
trailer and learn about the brand new hulk movie
and click here for my brand new she-hulk daredevil
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!